d'abord monsieur le sénateur j'espère
que vous ne vous offusquez pas de ce que
je fais les mêmes réponses aux questions
semblables à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat
c'est un signe de cohérence nous voilà
reese a aucun souci volontiers je vous
remercie de bien vouloir m'en donner
acte j'y tiens j'y tiens vous rappelle
que je dépose sous serment
ce qui est en soit intéressant 3 3
questions complexes et intéressante que
vous posez avant de répondre à ces trois
questions il remarque sur le rapport du
général du jury jeune mais je n'ai rien
à ajouter à ce que j'ai dit j'assume le
fait d'avoir commandé ce rapport
gco j'ai du mal s'agissant de moi a
communiqué un rapport dont je ne suis
plus destinataire puisque je ne suis
plus premier laurier transmis sinon bien
sûr
qu'est ce que voulait dire monsieur vous
intéresse si vous étiez premier ministre
en fonction quand le rapport vous aurez
été remis quand je veux faire de la
politique fiction j'écris des livres
monsieur le sénateur ce que je sais ce
que je sais monsieur le sénateur c'est
que à chaque fois j'ai transmis des
documents au sénat y compris au delà au
delà monsieur le sénateur de ce que la
loi imposait notamment en matière des
actes pris dans l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
donc soit vous avez des éléments mais je
je je ne suis pas sûr de comprendre
exactement le sens de votre remarque
moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
j'ai moi-même demandé au général lizurey
de produire ce rapport que le général
ils sûrs et a produit un rapport après
avoir participé à très nombreuses
réunions et après d'ailleurs nous avoir
dit à titre orale attention pensez à 6
attention pensez à ça ce qui était très
utile
et voilà une fois qu'il a rendu son
rapport
je ne crois pas être responsable de la
façon dont on gère les affaires de
l'état sur des décisions de cette nature
dès lors que ce n'est plus moi le
premier ministre
[Musique]